here we go again it's that time of the
month again Sony have revealed the
PlayStation Plus lineup for May 2017 as
always we have six games to get out
grubby little hands on across ps4 ps3
and the Vita to this month we have an
episodic adventure tale a twin stick
shooter a business sim and an
educational escapade hmm
all of these beauties will be available
from Tuesday May the 2nd as always let's
start off with the offerings on ps4 the
sake tales from the borderlands this is
a five-part interactive story from the
creators of The Walking Dead and
guardians of the galaxy and a whole host
of other story driven adventures don't
confuse this one with a fully fledged
Borderlands title this is not a
first-person shooter with randomized
loot elements so get that out of your
head as soon as possible but if you
truly want to understand all the
references in this story you should
really have played Borderlands 1 & 2 in
this one you play as a character who has
the dreams of being the next handsome
jack oh and also the Fiona of Pandora
and con artists looking for her next big
score these telltale games are honestly
brilliant and I firstly haven't tried
this one so I'm pretty happy about this
one what about you the second type of
may change depending on where you are in
the world in Europe we receive alien
nation a runnin gun twin-stick shooter
in this one you'll be leading an elite
squad of badasses fighting to save the
world from an alien invasion
this one is frantic to say the least the
environment is destructed all the skills
upgrades and weapon advancements keep
you cooked and coming back for more this
one really excels when you play it with
three other people so tell your friends
to download it - in North America you'll
be getting Abzu in this one you'll take
on the role of a diver in a huge ocean
after waking up on the ocean surface the
diver begins exploring the surrounding
underwater environments which are filled
with plant life and animals in addition
to uncovering ancient technology and
submerged ruins with puzzles to complete
and hidden area so uncover this one
could be a gem GameSpot gave this one 9
out of 10 so it's definitely worth a try
remember if these videos are useful
please like and subscribe if you haven't
already and help us reach more people
right let's get back to the PlayStation
Club game over to the ps3 game number
three is blood Knight which was released
in late 2013 this one is a hack and
flash role-playing game centered around
a vampire hunter and a vampire he's
bound to not literally of course this
one support local couch co-op what he's
really intended for a single-player
experience I won't beat around the bush
this one has an average rating of 4 out
of 10 so this one maybe want to avoid I
haven't tried it so please give me your
opinion if you have and either one is
off it or tell us to give it a go
our fourth title it cost royale 3 pirate
and merchant believe it or not but this
one is a business simulator yeah I was
shocked too so you'll be bombing around
the Caribbean in the 16th century
keeping your crew in coin but don't fret
too much because you'll only be counting
those coins after you beat settlements
and towns in a real time battle no less
I feel like a pro DS required here
what did the ocean say to the pirate
nothing it just waved hey listen maybe
they give this one a whopping 40 out of
100 are you going to try it let me know
if you are below and wait there's more
over on the Vita v free game for the
month is laser disco defenders it's a
shooter from last year this one has a
quirky ad style and lots of 70 disco
references to but the kicker is the
randomly generated level meaning each
playthrough will be different anyone
fancy trying this one if you're going to
give this a go please let us know and
finally our sixth and last game for the
month of May 2017 is Type Rider I know
this game is cross clay so it should be
available on your ps4 but the notes
released by Sony don't explicitly say
that anyway in this one you'll be
discovering the secret history of faults
and characters yeah that's really what
the note says it's basically an
educational game in which you learn
about typography in one level you'll
learn about the printing press - I'm
sure you'll all be downloading this one
right away so what are you grabbing this
month I'm pretty damn happy with tales
from the bottom and alien nation but
what about you what are you grabbing
please let me know below
I'm mothering from Playstation grenades
and as always I'll see you next time
[Music]